okay now what we want to do is sort of
carry this into Vector notation right so
if I were to give you now an example
okay let's actually think about a couple
of points and where they are and um
you've got ordered triples here
um but we can do this in component form
or in column vectors whichever is a you
know sort of most convenient to us okay
um if we have a think about where A and
B are again I'm going to do the same
thing I'm just going to draw myself
um sort of this interval a b but I'm
just going to label one of them as uh
I'll do it at the top actually
two comma what have I got here negative
three common ten and the other one is
negative 3 comma 12 comma zero okay
now what two negative 3 and 10 give you
is the position that you get to in
relationship to the origin right so um
if you were to start at the origin you
would go two units in the X Direction
three units in the negative y direction
and then 10 units in the in the positive
Z direction right but but A and B I
don't actually the relationship between
both of those points so I don't know how
to get from A to B I only know how to
get from the origin and I can like say
place the origin somewhere else right
place the origin sorry that's an O right
I've got the origin here so what I can
say is oh I know how to get to um o a
and I know how to get oh well let's do
that a bit more neatly over to O B but
what I want is some point in the middle
of a and b or not exactly in the middle
you can see I need the ratio two three
okay
so what I'm going to do is like we saw
before I'm going to divide up a b into
how many equal sections if it's two and
three
five fantastic you're far away is
announced but I can see your five so
that's perfect so let's do that uh let's
try and do it I'm gonna enable that like
so
uh I can do that a bit better I think
there we go so there are my five equal
sections and so there's some point C
right so we're going to label it like so
C and you can see me doing that in that
two to three ratio okay
now what I've got here if you want to
think about it this way right
to find C but using my Vector thinking
right can you see I can think of that as
going from o to a
like so so doing this vector and then I
can do a to c by thinking of it as some
fraction of a to B right I'm going to
say that one more time
um I can think of going from a to c uh
this this Vector here
I can think of that as some fraction of
going from A to B now the question for
you is what fraction is AC
yeah that's right because we just
mentioned that it's five equal sections
and to go to C it's only two of them
right so really the vector AC and I may
even just sort of write this in here AC
is equal to two-fifths of a b
and let's just pause right there right
do you see we've already done one of the
things that was mentioned in that um in
that syllabus dot point right what we're
doing is we're doing a scalar
multiplication of vector a b by saying
it's a proportion uh sorry AC is a
proportion of vector a b so it's how
much of it it's 40 of it two-fifths okay
so really what I need to do here is I
just need to work out what Vector a b is
and then I multiply it by two-fifths to
get AC and then I can combine that with
O A so let's go ahead and do that right
maybe you recall I'm just going to go
straight there that a b is equal to O B
take away O A like so right so you can
see uh I know where B is and I can write
that in column form and I know where a
is so I'm going to write that in column
form as well
so what have I got here I've got
negative 3 12 0.
and then I'm going to subtract that from
2 negative 3
10 okay
so I'd like to enlist your help here
everyone I'm going to combine this all
into one big Vector before I evaluate it
can someone tell me what are we going to
write for the X and then the Y and then
the Z component Sean can you help me out
with the X component
okay fantastic which of course we'll
evaluate in a second by the way even
though negative 3 minus 2 like of course
that's pretty simple right I am just
personally I'm so bad at doing this
arithmetic bit and just doing it in my
head and getting it right the first time
especially when there are all these
negatives flying around and that just
happens all the time right uh Mrs Ile
can you help us what's the Y component
going to be
and we'll take my negative three take
and then negative three so we know
that's going to become a plus in a
minute and then Ryan you want to finish
this off
zero minus ten excellent okay so let's
go ahead and let's evaluate that now so
you can see I'm going to get negative
five that's going to be 15 and then
lastly I get a negative 10.
now remember what am I doing with this a
b well I multiply it by an appropriate
scalar namely two-fifths in order to get
AC right now um I would normally not do
this in my book but because I want you
to be able to see my diagram at the same
time I'm just going to draw some columns
here so please forgive me
um and I've got some space on the right
hand side here so AC right
we said that that's two-fifths of a b
and oh look isn't that convenient the
vector that we just worked out for a b
uh they're all multiples of five it's
almost like this question was designed
for this right so I am going to put it
in here though negative 5 15 negative
10.
okay Ryan can you help me out I reckon
you could do all three of the components
um all at once can you tell me what to
get
negative two
six
and negative four wonderful
okay all right oh we've got agreement
there happy with that so we've got our
AC now remember what we've got here
right I've just um you just told me
actually how to get from a to c but that
does not that's a that's a displacement
right from a I actually need c in
relation to O and so what we're gonna
have to do is we're going to have to
string along Vector o a and then add
that to AC and that gives us OC does
that make sense so that's what gives us
this um this resultant Vector okay by
the way fancy word for you I don't know
if you've heard this one before but what
you're doing when you're joining those
two vectors together
um it's called concatenating very fancy
word but really it just means stringing
one thing along after another and the
way that we do that in arithmetic is you
just add them that's one of the really
nice things about Vector arithmetic
so therefore I can say I'll zoom out so
you guys can see the whole thing there
here we go
OC is just going to be
um OA
plus a c and um I think I'm gonna skip
some of the working here because I think
you guys are probably already there
um Sean can you tell me what you got
when you added everything yeah
yeah you take the time
negative seven sixteen and negative six
and negative six fantastic so we can see
um one of the I will say one of the
trickiest things about
um yeah no yes let's have a look we've
got those numbers right
excuse me
I think you've have you added to have
you added to a different uh component
for some of them
yeah yeah you have that's that's totally
fine right and this is this is actually
really good this is why our working is
so important right let's actually fix
that up so I can see the the negative
six is fine isn't it
of course this is 10 take away four Zoom
and then um yeah we've got out we've got
a few of our numbers mixed up here right
so it's actually going to be 2 plus
negative two so that's a zero isn't it
is that right yep and then we've got
negative three plus six so that's just
three is that feeling a little better
yeah there we go now I will say by the
way um don't feel too bad about this
right number one there's lots of just
numbers flying around number two
um and this is just one of the things
that I think is why 3D vectors is an
extension two rather than extension one
when you're working in two Dimensions it
is so much easier to just do a sense
check by just like you just draw it
right whereas in three dimensions
because you can't just draw it um at
least in a way that intuitively tells
you oh you're clearly in the wrong spot
right like you actually have to have an
abstract sense of it and then just
you've got to rely on your arithmetic
being really good right so I think
that's part of the reason why they put
3D into here um does that make sense
though you guys happy with that
amazing okay